Chromium is a really surprisingly exciting element.
We've had real fun in the lab and we've had full Kainos
fires, Neil nearly caught fire.
You're going to see some quite exciting things.
And also I hope learned something about the chemistry of this really interesting
element is played a big role in my life,
particularly in my research ever since I've been to school. Boy,
chromium is element number 24 in the middle of the so-called transition
metals in the first row.
It was first discovered or rather its first compounds were discovered
in the middle of the 18th century in mines in the Euro
mountains in Eastern Russia.
One of the minerals that was discovered was a very bright yellow
pigment lead chromate.
You can make it in the lab by dropping ammonium dichromate and we'll show
you another interesting reaction of that.
Later dropping a solution of ammonium dichromate,
which is orange into a beaker containing led
acetate, which is colorless well, slightly cloudy,
and you get these fantastically bright yellow precipitate
formed. It used to be called Chrome yellow and be used as a paint.
Now people don't really want to use lead salts in paints,
but you can still see this terrific color.
It's important to say that even for chemists like me to see this
reaction gets again is really exciting.
And particularly because the formation in the beaker is
governed by the swirling of the liquid and the mixing and you see really
beautiful patterns and it always gives me a thrill.
Then in the later 18th century,
a French chemist Louis evoke Lang discovered that you could convert
Chrome yellow into an oxide of chromium chromium trioxide
by treating it with acid later,
he reacted this oxide with hydrogen to make chromium metal
and discover the element.
I think it's just worth mentioning that the reason that so many elements were
discovered at the end of the 18th century, beginning of the 19th century,
is that's when the idea or the modern idea of chemical elements was
first formulated.
So before then people were not looking for chemical elements.
And once the idea was formulated,
a whole massive elements were found relatively quickly while we're talking about
Tremblant trioxide, it's one of my favorite compounds.
You may have seen an earlier video where I set off all the fire alarms in the
chemistry department,
by mistake with criminal trioxide and ethanol.
Yeah.
You forgot to switch it off.
Of got better. And I persuaded Neil to try this reaction himself.
You poor ethanol,
which is a compound of carbon hydrogen oxygen onto chromium
trioxide,
which is a compound that chromium where the chromium has given all its electrons
to the oxygen. It is a very powerful oxidizing agent.
It makes things burn and it really made the ethanol
Poor Niels beaker caught fire.
He sort of known perhaps that it would, if he'd watched my video,
he would have got the water
Reaction. Not only produces flames,
but it converts the chromium.
Trioxide into different oxide of chromium,
where there are some electrons on the chromium and it is bright green.
It is so-called chromium two oxygen, three,
some people call it chromium sesqui oxide.
[Inaudible].
And the flames all went on a GoPro camera,
but I'm pleased to say the GoPro camera was not injured.
So it'll survive for our next video.
This brings us back to the name chromium, which is derived from the Greek word,
meaning a color.
And you've heard of monochromatic and words like that.
And chromium forms the most amazing range of different colored
compounds.
You've already seen it going from red to green and you can get almost
any color you want.
And the reason that it has all these different colors is because as a
transition metal,
it has four D electrons and two S electrons.
So that's six electrons and in different compounds,
it gives different number of electrons to the neighboring atom.
And the colors are associated with the energy
levels of the electrons that are left on the chromium atoms.
So you have different numbers of electrons and the energy levels can
also differ depending on the atoms round it.
If the energy levels are far apart,
they will absorb blue light. And so the compound will look red.
If the energy levels are close together,
they will absorb red light and look blue.
You can see a really nice color change when you drop sodium chromate
into acidified hydrogen peroxide,
the chromate liberates the oxygen from the hydrogen
peroxide.
And part of the chromate is reduced.
That is, it receives the electrons.
And so the chromium goes to a greenish color. Now,
when you actually look at the experiments,
what Neil did was the T took a dropper full of the chromate
solution and stuck it at the bottom of the beaker and then squeezed it.
So the chromate solution went to the bottom.
It reacted immediately going a sort of greenish Brown color,
which if you'd looked very carefully,
you will see is actually a mixture of a blue compound and a green one.
But the oxygen that is liberated the bubbles go up to the
surface and as it goes up,
it takes up streams of this colored liquid.
So you have quite a strange, almost like a garden growing.
And again, for me as a chemist,
it's really exciting to see how these things behave.
You can't predict exactly what's going to happen.
So every experiment is exciting in the past.
We've done this reaction before where we did it the other way,
round pouring hydrogen peroxide into chromate solution.
And there you do get quite dramatic color changes. And as I mentioned,
a professor that I knew blew off two of his fingers with this reaction.
So you've got to be careful.
Neil did one other really spectacular reaction with the ammonium
dichromate now ammonium, which is NH four.
Plus if you think about it contains hydrogen, which can burn.
And on the other hand, it has chromate which can give up oxygen.
So if you like, it's got both the oxidant and the fuel all in one compound,
the bottle says careful,
explosive and Neal heated this up in a nice round
bottom flask, quite a sizeable flowers.
And when the reaction takes off,
it takes quite a bit of heating to get it going.
Then it looks just like a volcano because you have
the green chromium oxide being formed,
which looks a bit like lava and the flames shooting up.
All three of us Brady, me and Neil were really quite impressed by that reaction.
Unfortunately,
the filter that Neil used at the top wasn't strong enough
thermally to resist the heat. It caught fire, and then it melted.
But apart from that, the reaction was quite a success.
Chromium plating was used very widely in the United States,
in the car industry,
the automobile industry and with expensive cars were covered
in chromed components.
So they looked really shiny and silver nowadays,
people are trying to save weight on cars and you don't use metal for the
bumpers and things like that.
So there's almost no Chrome plating on cars.
Let me tell you about chromium in my research.
I've worked for many years with this compound chromium hexapod combination
chromium with six CEO groups round it.
If you isolated in a solid, it's a very low temperature,
minus 250 degrees,
you can irradiate UV light on it and generate chromium
Pentecost. Now chromium with five CEO groups around it,
which is enormously reactive and would react immediately and disappear.
If it was not frozen,
that's such low temperature and that sort of low temperature,
it will re even react with argon. We all think as are,
is really in gas. My fellow student,
Robin Perutz discovered it would react with argon and form a really nice
purple color.
I reproduced his experiment for my first lecture that I gave outside my own
university. I still showed the slide.
43 years on the lecture was a bit of a disappointment.
There was a Nobel prize winner. So George Porter, who was meant to be there,
but it turned out he had another engagement.
So I never saw him at the lecture.
It then turned out that CLC five will react with Xenon
I and my colleague, Tim Turner. My professor, um,
published the first paper in which CRC five seen none was discovered in
solution.
And now this is still a major research area, not Tignum.
And my colleague,
Mike George is using very fast spectroscopy to look at metal,
Xenon compounds.
Most school teachers don't know that see non will react with transition metals,
but it's now quite a widespread phenomenon. When I was a school boy,
aged 16, I passed my exams a year earlier than my classmate.
So I was allowed to do a research project all by myself.
Wouldn't be allowed nowadays for reasons I can't remember. Now,
I decided to look at the reaction of copper chromate and ammonia for
nostalgia state. I asked Neil to repeat this experiment,
taking copper sulfate, which is a blue solution,
adding to it,
a solution of sodium chromate and you get a rather
sort of muddy precipitate. Doesn't look at all appetizing.
And then if you add ammonia,
it goes dark blue.
If you haven't mixed it up properly like Neil hadn't and then it goes green.
Now,
what I want you to see from this experiment is it's a pretty messy
experiment and it was completely mad for me,
a school boy,
to try and study this reaction by re did it with great
determination. I never really discovered anything important,
but it did really hooked me on doing chemical research and I've been doing it
nearly ever since I was so devoted to this reaction.
I had a rack of test tubes with these different samples above my,
on the shelf of, by my bed in my bedroom.
I'm not sure what my parents thought of this.
Hi there everyone is,
this is the first video we've posted since passing 1 million subscribers.
I thought I'd take this opportunity to thank everyone.
Who's watching periodic videos,
a special thanks to everyone who subscribes a special, special,
thanks to everyone.
Who's used the little notification bell with their subscription, a special,
special, special, thanks to everyone who supports us on Patrion.
There's an address on the screen. Also,
if you're someone who's gotten into watching podcasts,
I thought I might tell you, I actually have two podcasts.
I do one with a fellow YouTuber called CGP grey. You may have heard of him.
And our podcast is called hello internet. And there's a second podcast.
I do a newer one called the unmade podcast that I do with an old friend of mine
called Tim. The names of them are on the screen.
You can find links in the video description or just search hallow internet,
or the unmade podcast on your podcast. Player of choice. Thanks for watching.
We'll see you again here soon.